[Laughter]
yeah go to your stations and deal with a
bunch of retirement questions
that's kyle van noy patriots linebacker
talking to rob gronkowski last week at
one of the umpteen media availabilities
and gronk was asked plenty of questions
about retirement all week long chris
after the game he said he'll make a
decision in the next week or two if
you're making a decision in the next
week or two in my mind you're announcing
a decision you've already made in the
next week or two this measures with a
theory that you and big cat had last
week that he's gonna wait for the right
moment after the super bowl to say what
he's doing so as not to take away from
the super bowl win and to kind of create
his own event where he can say i'm done
but if if if you if you're going to make
a decision that quickly the decision is
already made and i think that that that
he's done i think that if they'd have
won the super bowl last year he'd have
been done and i think now it's time for
gronk to move on plus if he does want to
stay there's no guarantee that the
patriots even want him no well i mean as
we know when the patriots feel like a t
a player is uh maybe coming to the end
or physically or mentally isn't checked
in all the way they will get rid of you
i mean that's what sounds like happened
last year um
you know how many coaches and i feel
like i've heard bill parcell say this i
mean if you're thinking about being
retired then you're retired really i
mean it's just not the type of sport
where you can have one foot out the door
and go well i'm not sure you know one
foot's out the door but i'm going to
stay inside here and still be a football
player no y
football is one of those sports that you
you have to live it you wake up every
day it's nutrition it's training uh it's
things that make your body stronger
healthier whatever it is and when you
stop living that way that's when
disaster happens usually uh and i just
feel like with gronk some of the answers
we've heard over the last year the lack
of emotion this season all of those
things would tell me that you know to
what you're saying mike that he's going
to come out here in the next 10 days and
say you know see you later
i'm going to pursue other things in life
there's a certain weariness that comes
from all the injuries he's had he's had
so many surgeries and the way that i
heard it last year when these rumors
first started to percolate family
members pressing him to get out because
of concern over concussions right
there's the concussions we know about
and then there are the concussions we
don't know about and you know the the
one that he suffered remember the afc
championship game when he got hit and
knocked out of that game right that's
the one i think that got his attention
now he didn't have one like that last
year and maybe the passage of time has
allowed him to to be
less concerned about it but i just
i don't think you make a decision within
a week or two if the decision is i'm
definitely coming back i think the
decision has been made and i think he
knows what he's going to do and i think
he's got plans made for opportunities to
make a lot of money just being gronk
whatever it is as an actor as a wrestler
as as a party host as a guy who gets a
cruise ship every three or four months
and takes a bunch of patriots fans out
on the high seas whatever it is gronk is
is a is a money-making machine and he's
never had to spend any of his football
money because of his marketing dollars
and maybe he's a guy who can continue to
milk that beyond the end of his football
career like peyton manning has yeah i
mean gosh i mean gronk could be the
terminator and the new version of that i
could totally see him be that guy i'll
be back have you ever seen him act
though he is so bad well he's so bad i
mean i wasn't trying to give arnold
schwarzenegger any oscars either early
on in his career either so it's okay i
mean but but hey as you know we've
talked about this a lot gronkowski his
body has been through hell in his career
i mean it's broken legs ankles shoulders
elbows concussions to what you talked
about he played the position as physical
as you can play it uh and he was an
amazing not only pass catcher but run
blocker as well and that takes its toll
greatest tight end of all time for for
my money and i think you agree
and yeah i agree and maybe he's
perfectly suited to be the terminator
takes tons of abuse and just keeps
going hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports